good morning it's tuesday today's video
comes to you in two parts part one a
major casting announcement so back in
march the hollywood reporter announced
that isabella merced would play aza in
the movie adaptation of my book turtles
all the way down and then shortly after
that deadline hollywood broke the news
that felix millard and cree would also
be in the movie but somehow none of
these major publications saw fit to
announce the most important news of all
which is that i have also been cast in
the turtles all the way down movie now
hank long time nerdfighters will know
that i have never managed to actually
score a cameo in any of the movie
adaptations of my books and not for lack
of trying like i was supposed to be in
the fault in our stars movie i had two
lines and everything but my acting was
so distractingly bad that they had to
cut the scene out of the movie but that
was eight years ago hank and since then
i have been practicing working to get to
a place where i can say words in a
normal-ish manner while looking into a
camera lens but also while being filmed
and not looking into a camera lens nope
no up speak just straight but also while
being filmed and not looking into a
camera lens that got weird at the end
but also while being filmed and not
looking into a camera lens
that was an angry version just say it
normal but also while being filmed and
not looking but also while being filmed
and not looking and but this is gonna go
great will i get cut from the movie
probably but that's okay i mean the work
actual actors do just amazes me like to
cite one example isabella so completely
inhabits the mind and body of aza that
sometimes when we are filming difficult
scenes i want to intervene like i know
it's acting there are cameras and mics
and lights everywhere but she makes it
feel so real that all that stuff
disappears which is something no one
will say about my performance in turtles
all the way down oh but there is one
great thing about it so there's this
document called a call sheet which says
like which actors are working each day
and when they need to be picked up and
stuff and the star of the movie is the
first person on the call sheet and then
the person who has the second most
screen time is number two on the call
sheet and so on anyway my first day on
the set the second assistant director
tracy came up to me and said it's really
nice to meet you 19 because i am the
19th name on the call sheet and now i
have a nickname the hair and makeup crew
even got me a necklace that has the
number 19 on it i've always wanted a
good nickname one that is simultaneously
loving and humbling i mean the thing
about your regular name is that it's
picked when nobody knows anything about
you including yourself whereas a
nickname is generally bestowed when
people do know something about you like
that you're the 19th most important
member of this cast last thing about the
movie i'll be doing more question
tuesday videos with the cast and also
with the director so leave some
questions in the comments below part two
crash course so hank it truly boggles my
mind to consider how many people have
used complexly's channel crash course to
help them learn like these days when i'm
running an errand and someone recognizes
me 99 of the time it's as the crash
course guy and i have to say the crash
course guy is my favorite nickname even
more than 19 because i am really proud
of the people who make crash course and
what they've accomplished together like
in 2021 alone they helped tens of
millions of people learn about
everything from organic chemistry to
black american history to infectious
disease which incidentally were three of
the series launched last year thanks in
part to funding from the crash course
coin the 2022 edition of which is
available now and only for the next two
weeks the idea is that people can
sponsor 2 000 learners with a 100 coin
or 10 000 learners with a 500 coin and
you get this beautifully struck coin
which features illustrations inspired by
the cave paintings at last go cave
paintings that remind us that people
have been sharing information and
learning from each other for a very long
time the link to get yours is
crashcoursecoin.com now of course we
know that the vast majority of people
can't afford to support crash course at
that level and that's okay the whole
idea of crash course is that it is free
for everyone forever but if you can
afford to it is a beautiful coin and
will also help crash course fulfill its
mission of lowering barriers to
education hank i'll see you on friday